bello a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj e ci siamo suter chiude
action praticamente ragazzi sarebbe un
gioco tipo l'avevo fatto secoli fai la
cosa più bella di tutte che hanno
aggiunto anzi che hanno tolto è il vero
che non esiste perché si parte così cioè
spiegatemi un gioco che parte che non
sai neanche come si chiama parte così ci
sono delle poltrone 20 ragazzi il sequel
si chiamerà poltrone di horror
experience a figo faccio un ipad 2 è
tirato fuori nei pressi or at wintour ex
io io dovrei entrare in un ascensore che
non va bene non fa niente ragazzi
provano sega guardia note ma scriventi
poi i numeri al posto dei no era troppo
difficile vero vabbè andiamo al piano
forcone uno dei migliori sempre quello
che giorno brake debord su starz jones
ha chiuso la porta in faccia bene e
crescere i ragazzi a porte stack agata
che la solita cantilena che ci dice sta
tizia prima di iniziare a cosa che devo
fare blackboard start farm va bene devo
come dell'omo ste cose che bei quadri
ragazzo voglio vedere se c'era o kay
sono partito che ma non c'è la minima a
questo hanno cambiato sa cosa che adesso
la minima
già la [ __ ] porca la tramissione cagato
addosso cats e 400 cioè non ce la farò
mai ragazzi voi lo sapete vero merda ma
sei stronzo nel cervello proprio vado
dicono ragazzi e abbiate pazienza
impossibile bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye era era 10.000 volte
più semplice ultima volta ne vado cazzo
domandava poi bello che non capisco il
senso c'è di qua io vado veramente non
ho capito il senso di più
l'n8 ti prendo a far ceffone in faccia
beh io non mi faccio neanche lo rifaccio
vicenda è ormai è una e una sfida contro
me stesso quindi scostò di no perché ci
sono altri livelli però non potrò farli
probabilmente se non fai sono finisco
prima questo il problema è che non
possono stimare andare avanti
hai finito di parlare il mi6 sul culo
zia ti prendo ti chiudi in una gabbia
ghosts e scimmia che ti inglobano merda
e vabbè allora sei stupido no noi cosa
mi co so come mi sono salvato non lo so
manco io sono salva possono essere arci
sulle poltrone novero dove sarebbe di
preciso non lo devo riuscire a prendere
con gli inviati
e vabbè vabbè ma mettiamo anche
qualcos'altro tipo che nei suoi
teletubbies ottiene un tablet sto tizio
nelle mutande ce l'hai un iphone non lo
so google maps qualcosa di più pratico
righe anche un tablet ma quanto sei
bella da una 10 non so neanche perché
con decisione
non so neanche perché ho riaperto sto
gioco continuando a fare questa domanda
che non avrà mai risposta ragazzi
purtroppo non so dove sono ma non
importa ragazzi queste con la buona non
ho incontrato ancora uno e non ne sto
prendendo tipo un miliardo anni passati
a giocare a pacman serviranno a qualcosa
però la fregatura che non vedo dove sono
quindi non so neanche se mi stanno per
spuntare davanti non ne ho idea
no non ti ammazzo il canarino di mele
che sono state inglobate anche a vicenda
adesso vai vai vai vai no no no non solo
a metà cristalli adesso vi rendete conto
di questa cosa quanto è triste ma
veramente ragazzi non so madonna
ho visto la morte in faccia tipo prova
beh non dipendo non lo vedono il meglio
che non lo vedo neanche quindi non so
neanche dove doveva beh no no no no no
se mille se me lo trova davanti uccido
qualcuno che culo costo trovato bonus a
calcio cosa sta stringendo sia quella
sta a parlare madonna cosa ho schivato
ma [ __ ] non c'era la strada non
c'era la strada non ci posso credere che
manca poco per favore chi ti giuro farò
qualsiasi cosa nella vita
non posso rovinarmi la vita così per un
gioco di merda che ti giuro che potevo
giocare i teletubbies ero più felice
preferivo poltrone horror experience a
temi un calmante una tisana un qualcosa
per questo gioco non è che fa paura ti
fa incazzare misto a paura rimarca pure
la borsa sentite che merda è una roba
orribile perché tipo non 66 incazzati o
spaventarti o se insultare la mamma di
qualcuno ridendo e scherzando siamo
tornati a 250 si spera si riesca a
qualcosa di decente almeno stavolta ecco
che non ti spuntino semi che cazzo parli
che sto parlando io comunque 230 sono
morte una volta un miracolo spacca tutto
bene perché stavo per morire lo so già
by così i ragazzi sono gasati va bene
non mi ha preso non mi ha preso lo meno
così tanto so che è ma lo sapevo lo
sapevo perché chi devo trucidare la
famiglia madonna come mi sono salvato
non lo so manco io quanti cazzo siete
147 segnatevi questo momento ragazzi non
ci arrivano mai più nella vita donna c'è
godono no no no no che culo che botta
assurda di culo fai così fai così forza
suo capo lo sapevo che c'era il problema
che adesso non ne troverò 26 davanti e
non è lo sapevo non ci sei vero non ci
sei non ci sei bravo bravo bravo bravo
ragazzo non so come tornare indietro
questo potrebbe essere un problema
ragazzi ci fosse non ci stai zitta 40 39
freddo o ragazzo sto sudando freddo ve
lo dico ai vari rai 31 30 21 28 forza
forza
non ci posso credere maledizione se mi
spunta davanti ad esso uccido qualcuno
10 non ci credo non ci posso creare
nuove 876 potrei morire di fili di
felicità 5 4 3 2 1 si è fatta notare
indietro
no no no mi incazzo giuro che mi incazzo
giuro che mi cadi che mi fa ripartire
soffrite piazzi chi è questo non lo so
vabbè lo collezionati lizard segno tutti
che cazzo vuoi l'ascensore chiama
qualcosina lo chiudi c'è scritto che vi
è stata i cani e ai fantasmi brutti
d'oro per i [ __ ]
la fai a chiudere questo [ __ ] è
chiuso troy on air è chiuso che cazzo
vuoi dalla mia vita ma perché chi cazzo
ma cosa vuoi che vada affanculo comunque
ragazzi credo sia finito qua perché
che brutto è questo ragazzo era
veramente comunque cosa dovrei fare a
testa ci sediamo sulle poltrone non so
cosa vuoi farti da guardia
adesso ti chiudo io dentro picchia
potevo morire di crepacuore se riuscissi
il 10 si chiude e vabbè comunque ha
concluso qui l'episodio perché non è
possibile nella vita che succede una
cosa del genere però ok non ho capito
bene se finiva così o se dovevo fare
qualcosa ma comunque in fantasmi stanno
troppo su cui i ragazzi conclusa poi
prima che l'anci il monitor fuori dalla
finestra spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto come se i ragazzi se il video è
piaciuta lasciato commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e come nel
miglio trattando estinzione se questi di
sky tree ci vediamo il prossimo vinto
belle ragazze